[Music]
hi there can you blink for me good can
you tell me how many fingers I'm holding
up before and what year is it 2016 yes
good and who's the President Barack
Obama who I jumped nothing happens the
way I imagined let me miss us it over I
[Music]
live here we travel into another
dimension
into other versions of ourselves
[Music]
do you understand what we're on the edge
of here
it's godlike very my name is Karim
Washington I've investigated looking
into the disappearance of a teenager I'm
staying at this house is this the
missing person but it looks like you've
seen a ghost
the image just reminds me of a young man
I knew in Michigan it's all connected we
can get to the bottom of it
you're tougher than you look you're
kinder than the scene Oh
Rachel Scott and Renata
BBA in the voice I asked to believe in
impossible things
never once looked at me like I was crazy
everyone who goes inside this house it
comes out cracked up or doesn't come out
at all you gotta open your eyes I cannot
give up on you this is not a time to be
brave this is the time to be smart this
beauty
energy
what holds it together
what keeps it him dissolving into noise
q spots in 5/4
to
Wow
[Music]
[Music]